so SUNY which is the State University up
in New York they've got a lot of
campuses all 64 campuses will now
require freshman students to complete a
diversity Equity inclusion and social
justice course this will be a
requirement for graduation now you'll
you'll hear the squishy people say well
this is this is an assault on academic
freedom you're going to hear the squishy
people on both sides say that this is an
assault on academic freedom to try to
ban the Dei classes or this is an
assault on academic freedom to require
students to take the Dei classes but I
have no problem with students being
required to take certain classes in fact
I I wish that I had been required to
take more specific classes I wish that
the Common Core Curriculum not common
core like the terrible math program in
schools but I mean the the core the
Western Canon the great books I wish
that were still being mandated in
schools it no longer is I see no problem
with requiring students to take some
classes
they just shouldn't be required to take
these classes